Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
Babel. Continuing
[Silence]
a narration that
Noah
mentions as the third consecutive
narration in this chapter, the fifth
chapter of the chapter of vigilance of
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
we could go ahead and read the first
portion of the narration that we've
already covered.
forch.
[Silence]
He mentions the narration of Ib. He says
Abbass
narrates that one day I was behind the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
writing
and he said to me young boy I'm going to
teach you
some truths
be preserve the boundaries of Allah the
commandments of Allah the prohibitions
of Allah and Allah will preserve you in
turn
preserve Allah and his boundaries and
his prohib prohibitions and you will
always find him before you. If you ask
then ask Allah and if you seek aid then
seek aid in Allah and know that if all
of the world were to collaborate
to attempt to benefit you with something
they could only benefit you with that
which Allah has already written for you.
And conversely, if they were to
collaborate, to attempt to harm you with
something, they could only harm you with
that which Allah has already written
again upon you. The pens of decree have
already been lifted from the pages and
those pages have since dried. This
narration is been collected by
Abisa
in his sun and graded by as being
authentic and it is as he has said. Now
there is another addition another
portion
outside of
it's actually inbah
addition to this in which Ib adds that
the prophet sallallahi wasallam added
which is the same meaning as
preserve Allah's boundaries
and
preserve and adhere to Allah's
boundaries and laws, prohibitions
and obligations
etc. And you will always find him in
front of you. You will always find him
there before you.
get to know and become familiar to Allah
in time of ease
and Allah
will
know you in your times of difficulty.
This is a very key component
which separates the believer from the
non-believer.
There is nothing unique
per se
about a person who is afflicted with a
calamity or difficulty, finds himself in
a crisis
and calls out to Allah.
Everybody does this. Every human being
when the illusion of independence
drops,
a person is faced with just how weak and
helpless he is and how in need he is of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in those
moments of difficulty and crisis and
tragedy etc.
Everyone calls out to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
However, what is unique
is someone who sees through that
illusion in times of ease. In times when
most people fall asleep, most people
become deceived by the illusion. Most
people start to believe
that illusion of independence.
The believer
continuously sees his
absolute
dependence on Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and this is what is most counted for a
person.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has mentioned
that the disbelievers the mushri
of Mecca those who had rejected the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam's
call to Islam so staunchly
and so vehemently that those same
individuals
when they per for instance were would
find themselves on a boat and the sea
becomes chaotic
and they fear death and fear
destruction.
Those same worshippers of
those same idoltors, those same men that
would otherwise die in defense of their
idols would then abandon their idols and
call to Allah alone without any
partners.
This is something that Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
throughout the Quran
as an evidence
an evidence a testimony from a person's
own self to what he really believes.
and so this is something that is not
very unique. What is unique
is that a person in times of ease, in
times when the illusion of independence
is most
is most captivating, is most
deceptive, is most inviting. The person
still remembers Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala, still obeys Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. That is when a person is able
to truly build a strong and meaningful
relationship with Allah. Not when things
are going bad, but when things are going
good. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that the human being is most prone to
disbelief when he is in times of ease.
He says, "Subhanala
that the human being will transgress
mainly when he sees himself as
independent, not in need of anyone else,
not in need of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so
when is a meaningful relationship built
with Allah? It's built during times of
ease. It's built during times of
comfort. It's built during times when
most people would forget. When the
nature of the human being kicks in to
forget and enjoy and fall asleep, this
person remains vigilant of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala during this time.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us the
story of Ununus.
What is it that saved you from the belly
of that whale?
What does Allah sight as the thing the
saving grace for you?
It was his worship. Correct?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
Allah says
that
Once he was swallowed by the whale, had
it not been for his t meaning worship,
general worship of Allah, obedience to
Allah, he would have remained in that
will's belly until the day of
resurrection. Now,
is there any person alive or dead? Any
human being that has ever existed
that would be swallowed by a whale?
Any human being whose sanity is still
intact that would be swallowed by a
whale? Swallowed by a whale and not call
out to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Where is this person?
Bring me the most avid, staunch,
vehement, vicious atheist
and let a whale swallow them. They will
call out to Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
alone without any partners perfected in
that moment. Right?
So then what is
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala referring to
here in this verse? He says,
that he was someone who obeyed and
worshiped Allah before
the whales swallowed him. Not not after.
Yes, after he called out to Allah,
but before the whale swallowed him, he
had a strong relationship with Allah. He
had built a strong relationship of
obedience to Allah
before that incident. He had
he had an account
of worship with Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. So when he needed Allah,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
responded
as the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam teaches us here. He says
he says build that relationship with
Allah.
Obey Allah in times of ease
and Allah will recognize you and
acknowledge you and answer your prayer
and deliver you in your times of deepest
need. Right? This is the most critical
difference between the believer and the
disbeliever. between the one who has a
meaningful relationship with Allah and
one who doesn't. Everyone calls out to
Allah in times of hardship. It is only
the
believer that calls out to Allah in
times of ease.
And honestly, every single one of
these sentences is a principle by which
a person is to live his life and a
principle by which a person is to
understand the Quran. He says in the
next sentence,
back.
Subhan Allah. He says, "And no, be
certain, have no doubt
that whatever has afflicted you could
never have missed you, was never meant
to miss you,
and that whatever
has missed you was never meant to
afflict you." The whole concept of close
call
almost.
This is a concept for human beings who
are messy and ignorant and unable to
compute all the variables. We have
things that. Right?
However, with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
there is that which is and that which
isn't.
Right? There is
that which afflicts a person.
Even if it just seems it if just
one little thing would have changed,
that wouldn't have happened. No, that's
an illusion. It was never meant to
miss that person.
Right? I'll give you an example.
A person jumps in his car, drives down
the road. As he's driving down the road,
he passes,
let's say, a drunk driver.
They get killed. They get hit by this
driver. They get killed.
that moment when they their path
intersected with this other driver that
ended up the cause of claiming their
life.
What
could have changed
or what was needed to change in order
for him to miss that to leave his house?
If he would have dropped his keys
at the door of his car and bent over to
pick the keys up, they would have missed
it.
That would have never happened, right?
That's the illusion.
If he would have jumped in his car and
as he's backing out, a dog passed behind
his car. He had to pump the brakes for a
second. That one second completely makes
them what? makes their paths miss each
other. They would have never crossed
paths.
That's the illusion.
That is the illusion by which
the non-Muslim, the disbeliever, the one
who does not see by the decree of Allah
sees the world.
As for the believer, what does our
prophet teach us? Doesn't matter if it
was one second or one hour or one year
or one century. It was written.
That's why we're taught to say what when
something happens. When it's happened
and it's done, what are we taught to
say?
That is the decree of Allah. And what he
has willed, he has done. That's what
we're taught to say. Not almost if only.
This is the wording of the disbeliever
in the Quran. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
[Silence]
you meet.
He says, "Oh, you who have believed, do
not be the disbelievers, those who
say to their brothers, their comrades,
when they are claimed by death
in battle or in travel. If only they had
stayed home, they would not have died."
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that is
merely an illusion that is used by Allah
as a punishment for their disbelief to
cause them agony in their hearts
but really it is Allah who gives life
and takes life
doesn't matter if it was in this trip
often times we look at it as the person
left
the person crossed the street and the
car hit them and they died.
And the idea is if they hadn't crossed
the street, they would have lived. This
is incorrect. Really, the understanding
of Allah's decree is what?
This person died because Allah wrote for
him to die at this moment. Crossing the
street is just incidental,
right? You could not have avoided that.
If this person were to be locked down by
the department of of of defense
to not cross that street and Allah
subhanahu wa tala had written that upon
him, he will cross that street. There is
no way to avoid that with respect to the
decree of Allah. Now that doesn't mean
that people aren't held account. They
are held to account. This is not our
discussion. Our discussion now is
something that happens. Could it have
not happened?
The answer is Allah had decreed it. We
will continue this inshallah
in our next
gathering
and